say son it's been the ambition of
millionaires to have their heads frozen
in liquid nitrogen and at some point in
the future when we can cure many
diseases like cancer and things will
simply revive them and in that sense
attain a certain amount of immortality
well the double is in the details first
of all if you suddenly freeze the human
body the problem is that ice crystals
begin to form inside the cells as the
ice crystals expand they rupture the
cells so in other words freezing the
human body seems to work only
superficially but if you look at the
human tissue in the microscope you find
massive tearing and disruption of cell
walls now you may say to yourself now
wait a minute fish do it right don't
they simply get frozen solid and
wintertime frogs aren't they being able
to thaw themselves out when it's
springtime from a block of ice and the
answer is yes but they do it with
antifreeze that is glucose here's how it
works you know you put antifreeze inside
your car so even though outside
everything could be frozen solid but
inside your car liquid still flow
normally and so your car still runs in
the same way glucose is an antifreeze
for frogs and certain fish that their
bodies could still be in liquid form
with blood circulating even though they
are frozen solid on the outside now this
doesn't mean that at some point in the
future we might be able to create a
natural kind of antifreeze for the human
body however at the present time the
levels of glucose found in frogs and
fish that enable them to undergo
substantive animation would kill a human
being so it would take genetic
engineering so I'm not saying it's
impossible I'm just saying that those
organizations that advertise that you
can live forever this way may be
misleading the public because when the
body is thought out what you have is
dead tissue
you